right now hello my name is wanna job and
I'm from Nigeria I'm a global shaper
from the Lagos hope I am a greater
presenter producer and writer as well so
I'm going to answer the question from
Wendy buckle Minh on facebook and she
asked what would you like to be
historically remember no i think i'd
like to remember to my work and the
impact that in mills because I enjoy
what I do I enjoy writing I enjoy being
on radio I enjoy journalism itself but
ultimately it without impact and how it
affects other people and just course
mercifully changing attitudes changing
minds and I'm just making people
understand the world and the space
wearing a little bit more and then I
think that is definitely what I want to
be my friend let my work out give me I
let the impact and the effects that
happens it will let it all out leave me
so so that even when I leave this world
it can go on defined it's not just about
me anymore it's about the global the
global world memorial space that we're
in so i always think local so even if we
work in a local capacity it has to have
a big impact on the recipes as well